Put away your "The end is near" signs, all you apocalypse predictors.
That 2012 date you thought the ancient Mayans set for the big adios appears to be bogus.
Archaeologists working at Mayan ruins in Guatemala...
...discovered a six-foot square room whose walls are covered...
...with 12,000-year-old astronomical records of Mayan scribes,...
...who used these observations to accurately chart their culture's famous calendar.
The newly discovered calculations suggest Mayan math geeks...
...were actually projecting 6,000 years into the future,...
...scrambling everyone's doomsday plans and rendering John Cusack thriller plots moot.
At 600 years older than any other Mayan calculations,...
...this new discovery is the original.
So maybe we can rest a little easier...
...and maybe Saturday Night Live was right after all about the reason for the 2012 fearmongering.
Man, you just ran out of space and stopped didn't you?
No, that is not the case.
That's a lie.
Okay, yes, you got us.
We ran out of space.